hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday October 30th
2023 what's going on how are you how's
it going with you are you in your car do
you hate your
life it's not somebody else's
fault so don't be a [__] let them in and
go get yourself a donut
[Laughter]
uh oh my God I got a [__] headache I
caught my son's
cold Jesus Christ I caught a cold that's
the [__] you know why I caught a cold
you know why that is don't you he got
that [__]
vaccine he got vaccinated and now he got
a [__] cold do you know that was
actually something somebody was
saying on [__] social media the worst
part of and the best part of my job is
social media social media because I can
promote things can you promote things
yes I can like what well I can promote
Joe bartnik My Buddy Joe the rose bold
tailgate Legend he's coming home right
they say he can never go home but you
know Joe bartnik he's a [__] Rebel he
is going home bartnik is going to be in
Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania on November 11th at the
olev Brewery l o Lev tickets are going
fast because his special is crushing for
all things comedy which I knew it would
so go check him out now if he has too
much pigment if his mustache is too
intimidating if he looks too much like a
linebacker coach and you're more into
Dungeons and Dragons you could maybe go
see me I'm going to be I have upcoming
shows uh I of course don't have the
dates these are the cities I'm going to
be in all right I'm doing
Boston at the TD Bank North Garden
November
4th all right that's going to
be the Dennis lirry Cam Neely thing one
of my favorite things to do it's like a
standup reunion and also it's a great
cause that's November 4th at the TD Bank
North Garden home of your 80 in1 Boston
[__] Bruins I saw the Celtics beat
the Knicks the other night I'm also but
before and then after
that uh I go to one of those [__]
casinos there
Foxwoods the next day I think that's
November 5th then I have a day off on
the 6th and then on the 7th I'll be in
northfalk
Virginia all right who they had a big
they had a big victory against the Miami
Hurricanes I believe uh Virginia did I
don't know where the [__] their school
is because I didn't study in high school
one of the stupidest things I ever
[__] did not because I wanted to make
something in my life because I want to
go to a school that has a sports program
that I can actually give a [__]
about right after that okay we're going
to do the we'll do the the the dates and
then my disappointments after that uh
was it 6th 7th 8th I'll be in Atlanta
Georgia one of my favorite [__]
States favorite [__] people worse
[__]
traffic than uh Los Angeles I put it
right up there it is the LA of [__]
as far as traffic goes and then I'm
going to be in Hollywood Florida that's
how [__] Hollywood I am now even when
I go to Florida I have to go to
Hollywood did I go to Tampa where the
real people are go over to Orlando
huh go hang out with Tiger Woods in his
gated community no I'm not I'm going to
Hollywood
Florida and then I'll be at Madison
Square Garden and then after that all I
have is I have a date in Las Vegas and
then old Billy sick face is done for the
year and all I'm gonna do is play with
my kids love my wife play some drums and
get a cup of coffee I mean that that I
mean that's what life is Right life is
[__] simple let's let's get let's get
to what I saw on [__] Instagram I I
finally realized that I'm a simple man
okay and that is a nice forgiving way to
say that I'm a [__] Meathead all
right so I need to keep [__] simple I
need my life to be [__] simple all
right um so these [__] people on
Instagram I was saying how
um social media is a blessing in a curse
it's a blessing if you're a performer
because you can promote your projects
right provided there isn't a
strike but the thing about it is is it's
so [__] I am so [__] addicted to
Instagram I'm not addicted to my phone
I'm addicted to Instagram let's stop
blaming the phone phone all right but
the phone is the Gateway that is the
gateway drug to getting on Instagram cuz
I don't know how else to be on Instagram
I guess I could do it on my computer but
I just think like why would I have this
big [__] stupid thing when I could do
it on this little thing and I just go on
this thing and I just I [__] scroll
and scroll and scroll and scroll this
what I do I was off that [__] I broken
the habit I was reading books imagine
that can you even imagine dumb Billy Bur
[__] reading books that's what I was
doing I was I was on a [__] tear I
read like four books this year all right
that's like one every [__] 72
weeks actually is 52 shut the [__] up
you [__] math major [__] you have
your problems too all right I'm a sick
man I'm in a bad
mood um not a bad mood I just have a
[__] splitting headache splitting I
wouldn't say splitting I have an
annoying headache I could handle it but
I got got to do a podcast all right so I
want you guys to feel bad for me I want
I want to be considered a hero can I be
considered a first responder because my
podcast comes out on
Mondays you
know I want people to come up to me and
thank me for my
service I mean that's what it's be
everybody's becoming a [__] hero used
to be heroes Were
Heroes people did Brave [__] now
everybody's a [__] hero right
I think if you get a [__] hmer from a
[__] don't did you have to thank her
for her
service probably
do you know I love how women like act
like them having sex with you as they
did you a [__] favor like they didn't
have a good time too like they were
somehow put
out by having physical pleasure it's one
of the they are fascinating how no
matter how good it is I'm not even
talking sex I mean life no matter how
good it is they're still they're still
[__] put upon oh is this the headache
or am I or am I uh what dropping truth
bombs is that what the kids said five
[__] years ago so anyways I'm on the
Instagram on Instagram I look at drum
videos all anything music anybody
crushing anything in music I watch that
and I look at people that [__] have
badass cars and [__] motorcycles and
every once in a while I'll see a fitness
model but I know not to click on it cuz
once should do the entire [__] your
entire [__] search becomes [__]
fitness models all right I looked at one
I looked at 5,000 [__] cars how come
it's not all cars you know you know why
cuz [__] are lwh hanging fruit and I
know they say they're fitness models but
let's be honest they're [__] horse
all
right you can do yoga with clothes
on Jesus
Christ um I actually sent my wife one I
was watching there was this woman we'll
call her a woman all right I don't think
other women would call her a woman but
if I called her what she really is then
all of a sudden I'm an [__] so she
was doing a cooking video slash showing
off for [__] cleavage and her ass
like how many times have you seen
somebody's ass in a [__] cooking
video it just it's impossible and she
like looking over her shoulder like I'm
making a pumpkin spice latte right
so it was literally
soft soft cor
P she was making like pumpkin Donuts or
something she was [__] gorgeous but
it's like she's making the donuts and
her perfect titties are like hanging
like right above the banner and [__]
it's like I just went into the comments
cuz I wanted to see everybody saying
what did she cook nobody
know right God bless her God bless her
why would you want to get a [__] job
everybody's going to treat you like [__]
and not want to [__] pay you if
you're a good-look woman get out there
and [__] it up on Instagram I say um so
anyway uh I don't know where the [__] I
was but somewhere you know it was that
classic Instagram [__] where somebody
just makes this bold statement with no
[__] evidence behind it and one of
the things that they said was Amish
people never get
sick all right and there was no stats
there was nothing to prove that
statement and everybody just went with
it Amish people don't get sick why
because this [__] guy we don't even
know his background if he even knows any
Amish
people and the whole time what is the
dude or the lady what what are they
doing they're selling a book on [__]
home redies so they just start with this
big statement reminds me of that Robert
Klein he had this great joke making fun
of late night TV back in the day before
the internet these these [__] people
teaching you how to how to make money
money right and he goes like they start
off they go okay so he goes all right
you have no money so you buy a house
right
like and then you take the equity from
the house you don't own and blah blah
right they was doing like that [__] this
is this this guy just starts and this
lady starts with obish people never get
sick they don't get cold because they
they do this concoction of natural honey
onions garlic I don't know what the [__]
it was right so of course he doesn't
just give you the recipe it's in his
[__] book it's like why can't you
just give me who somebody gave you the
[__]
recipe Why couldn't you pass it on to us
now we got to buy your book we got to
buy your book cuz you don't want to work
for the corporate [__] so everybody's
just taking a [__] slice out of every
which reminds
me okay I was in [__] Reno today this
morning I had a great [__] time I
love that City that city is so [__]
cinematic IC like how the Cohen Brothers
have never shot a [__] movie down
there is is just beyond me all right I
had an unbelievable cup of coffee at
this place uh uh midnight coffee with
this this amazing Chef like I don't know
he grows his own beans I don't tote
roasts his own beans I don't know what
it was but it was [__] outstanding it
was like really strong but smooth you
know what I mean like a great bourbon Oh
Billy misses the BB Oh Billy bourbon
face Billy bourbon face at night
Billy sad face in the morning Billy
apologizing at 10: a.m. oh yeah that was
my life
um so anyways I had a great time they
treated me amazing the crowd was [__]
awesome and I just had like the perfect
day right so I go to the [__]
airport uh and we missed breakfast so we
sit down so I order a fried chicken
sandwich and the lady says to me she
goes do you want chips with that or do
you want to upgrade to
fries and I looked at her and I said
fries is an upgrade she said yeah it's a
it's
$4 I'm like are you out of your [__]
mind french fries come with the
sandwich okay french fries are are that
tag along [__] I'm going to upgrade
to fried [__]
potatoes you know I want somebody okay I
need a
whistleblower somebody that works in in
Corporate America and like how do you
guys sleep at night when it used to be
the customer is always right and now
your whole [__] motivation is how can
we [__] him in the ass another inch
deeper this
week you know you know what's [__]
funny is they're just going to do that
that that they're going to act like
french fries are an upgrade the same way
they act like you know avocado you know
can I get some guacamole on that burrito
guacamole is extra
why I got a [__] avocado tree in my
goddamn yard I'm not in [__] Maine
why am I paying extra for [__]
avocados and you what's funny they don't
even get [__]
avocados out here they get them from
Mexico people like why do they do that
CU they don't want to [__] pay
anybody I don't even know if they use
avocados here in California I have no
[__] idea somebody just said that the
same way this so right now you know what
we need to start baning together as
people all right you want to upgrade
french fries don't take it out on the
waitress it's not hurt don't don't Don't
Kill the Messenger all right just say
no just look at her and say french fries
should come with the sandwich I'm
offended by that question I will take
the potato chips okay and if enough
people [__] say that they still won't
do
anything what they'll do is they'll put
a chemical in the [__] potato chips
that will make you
lust for French
fries that's what they do in the [__]
food industry the food industry does not
look at drug
addicts in a sad way they look at them
they look at it in an envious way they
look at heroin and [__] all of these
goddamn [__] crazy drugs meth and all
that with envy and they go can can you
imagine if we could create food fiends
and that's what they did with salt and
sugar and chemicals and all of this [__]
and these [__] piece of [__] people
in the government who don't give a [__]
just let them do it so that's that's
what the problem is your problem is our
problem now becomes like how do I get
off sugar like I've beat I've beaten
sugar so far right I'm sober now from
sugar I just had this I just make I just
said it out loud I said I don't eat
desserts right which is a great thing to
[__] do you know because I hate going
to the [__] gym all right but if you
eat a [__] dessert one [__]
dessert wipes out three days at the gym
you just spent three days on a [__]
elliptical throwing weights around
trying not to look at that chick's ass
trying to be a [__] good guy for
what for what all you did was just wear
out your [__] joints making your btis
slowly turn into arthritis that's what
you did and then you ate a bunch of
[__] sugar negated what you did and
now sugar inflames your [__] joints
[__] up your shoulder even more it's
a goddamn gang bang that's what the [__]
it is uh they're out to get you oh Jesus
bill you take a little nightquil this is
this Billy nightquil right here old
night night William Billy night
night so anyways these stupid [__] it's
not stupid [__] this [__] guy's
selling this book so he just makes this
statement Anish people never get sick
they never get [__] sick that's
fascinating they never get sick right
because of this concoction that he won't
tell you how to [__] make it he tells
you a few of the ingredients but you got
to buy the book and then like that
wasn't [__] insulting
enough all right the way he's not going
to tell me the way if you get into that
[__] that meditation what is it not
that tantric [__] that's so you can [__]
for nine hours why would you ever want
to do that
um trans transcendental [__]
meditation I was just like you know what
I'm a psycho I need to I need to do that
and there's no place where you can learn
it they just won't teach you how to do
it anywhere you have to go there and
then they talk to you and then they
figure out what the word is that comes
you down and they give you a special
word and you pay them and then they
teach you how to meditate that's what
the [__] we did with meditation which
wasn't even ours we took from it I
believe it all came from
India right I don't how the [__] you
follow the [__] paper trail all the
paper trail does here go back to the
founding fathers those [__] [__]
taking credit for everything all right I
don't trust a man in a wig okay I don't
trust a man with toue I don't trust a
man with a [__] hair system okay so I
don't give a [__] about these founded
fathers they all look miserable they all
look like they needed to go outside the
[__] Sun so
anyway I go into the comments section on
this [__] Instagram stupid ass
[__] post and there was people in
there
claiming that the reason why people gets
get cold is because they got the jab
they got the [__]
vaccine and I'm like are these just like
robots saying this [__] to make people
flip out and comment it has to be that
the person is literally acting like no
one ever got a cold until after they
came out with the vaccine which wasn't a
vaccine it's more of like a booster
shot uh but before that nobody got a
[__]
cold and it's that type of [__] that
makes me put my phone down and then I
walk around and I argue with somebody I
don't even I don't even know if they're
[__] real and I kind of had this
Epiphany last night going like I have to
get off of this [__] thing but I
can't get off of this [__] thing
because it is a monster when it comes to
[__] promoting my [__] it's a direct
line to people that like my stupidity
you know so I have to be on it so I got
to figure
out I don't want to got to figure out
okay I'm just a sick man alone in a
chair
wearing
pajamas having flannel pajamas oh this
[__] Cold's just taking a hold of me
I just turned the [__] corner you
know when you think you're going to
fight it off with your stupid little
[__] sticks whatever those [__]
things are called Zam the secret is to
take it right as you feel the cold
coming on well I did it and I still got
a [__] cold all right
so you know why that is cuz you live in
a liberal [__] city which isn't even
liberal if you've been out here it's
liberal in Hollywood no you go [__]
half an exit
down uh all right so anyway how about
the NFL
football [__] Pats lose
again Patriots lose again whatever you
know we had a great two decade run I'm
[__] I'm all right with it it's hard
watching Bill bich lose though
um I think eventually we will turn turn
it around but anyway plowing ahead here
um I bet the [__] uh I bet the
goddamn
Ravens laying eight and a half against
the [__] Cardinals and I swear to God
I had to go for a [__] walk after
that
game you know what I mean it was just
like first of all they should have beat
the [__] out of him and what happens
they're actually losing at the half okay
and that happened I I can handle that I
also took the Chiefs and for some
unfuckingbelievable
you know I was actually watching the
Bengals in the 49ers which was fun to
see Joe burrow healthy and just picking
apart that [__] defense and that's a
great defense and the balls he was
throwing the catches the guys were
making and how great their front four
played on defense I mean it was
fantastic great [__] game right and
I'm looking at the ticker right because
you know it's [__] overrated the NFL
package is so [__] stupid it's you're
not watching 16 [__] games it's
stupid it's just dumb I always end up
watching the network [__] game gonna
watch some random [__] game because I
got money on it I'm getting these not
ready for Prime Time [__] announcers
I want [__] Tony Romo I want Chris
Collinsworth I want the [__] big boys
right so I'm watching the goddamn ticker
and and I don't know what happened they
were up I I swear to God they were up
like by [__] 20 points and I'm like
oh my God I'm gonna win I'm gonna go two
and two this week I can handle two and
two I'm an adult win some you lose some
that's life life could be a dream life
could be a dream whoop boop boop sorry
I've seen cars like a million
times
um and then all of a sudden the 49ers
Bengals game ends and they they switch
over to the
[__] Cardinals Ravens and the [__]
Cardinals are lining up for a field goal
and they're down by 10 and I'm going
what the
[__] they hit this feel go I'm going to
I'm going to lose my [__]
bet what the [__]
happened so they [__] hyped the ball
and right as the kicker coming in they
blow the [__] whistle all right the
guy misses the field goal of course
would have
covered what happened fall start no go
[__] yourself on the offense that's a
five yard penalty re [__]
kick the second I saw that I'm like he's
going to hit this
one it was close but he [__] hit it
and I lost and I was CH I [__] went
on can you believe it I went on a tie
raid I lost my [__]
temper oh my
God what am I
doing I'm betting on a sports League
that doesn't that won't call itself a
sports League that's like having a
girlfriend that's uncomfortable with
calling herself her girlfriend you know
what that means that means she's got
some dick on the side the fact that
these sports leagues call themselves
entertainment
leagues because that's the one [__]
thing the government pays attention to
for some reason if there's a fixed
[__] game oh they got to get in there
and they got to get to the bottom of it
to make sure they [__] like act like
they're doing their [__]
jobs
oh Jesus
Christ I literally just lost my [__]
train of thought I'm so okay
so yeah they call themselves a [__]
Sports League I'm walking around right
now reliving this loss they call
themselves sports leagues and now
they're in bed with Vegas they're in bed
with gambling
organizations and I'm supposed to sit
there and act like this is all on the up
and up I'll tell you right now if I've
learned [__] anything in my 31 plus
years in show businesses everybody has a
[__] side deal don't ever forget that
everybody has a [__] side
deal
onside kick oh my God [__] recover
it I know this is just the babblings of
somebody who lost a bet what the [__] am
I doing doing that
[__] cuz it's fun when you
win yeah the whole world doesn't even
you get to a point in a certain age
you're like nothing makes sense and it's
never going to make
sense you
know like the level of enlight you have
to be individually to human beings
now you know is there literally a
cricket in my [__]
room you hear that or is that just the
sound of people not listening to my
[Laughter]
podcast crickets are talking to each
other this [__] guy's losing his mind
he's [__] sitting alone with Pajamas
yelling about a [__] game that has no
effect on his
life now the level of sensitive and
understanding that you have to be as an
individual to another
individual which I don't think is a bad
thing and they're basically saying don't
be an [__] right don't say this say
this do you know all right I don't have
a problem with that you know you can't
make fun of fat people right they're
struggling they're addicted you know
they're [__] junkies they're food
junkies we have to look at them like
they have a [__] disease and all that
you can all of that [__] yet war is
legal you can still have War you know
and it's just reported on you know
like this is just part of life like how
come all of this [__] that's being
outlawed and all of this stuff you can't
say like solving our problems with war
is still a
[__] a way to go as we're evidently
going to enter [__] World War III you
know what would be amazing if everybody
around the world just quit their army
just like [__] that we're not we're not
doing it we're not [__] doing it you
know what because everybody I I've been
around the world I've been in all of
these different [__] countries and
you know what people are
cool people don't want
problems they don't they want to find
the person that they should spend their
life with they want to start a family or
maybe they don't maybe they want to just
go solo but they they nobody wants to
[__] go around killing people psychos
want to do that you know just every
[__] country whoever's running their
country is a [__]
psycho they're [__] psychos
I I just I don't know and they it's just
like they're the ones that should be
fighting why just in a perfect world
that would [__] happen perfect world
people would be like french fries are
not an upgrade and we're not fighting
your [__] War okay if you have a
[__] problem you two [__] guys go
fight to the death you know put it on
after the
UFC this world leader versus this world
leader right and they can fight each
other whoever [__] wins all you get
is you get to say I killed that other
[__] psycho and there'll be one less
psycho and then we'll give the psycho a
[__] belt so he can feel like a
[__] Champion we you let him live on
the Hills so he can look down at us and
then the rest of us just be who we are
[__]
[Laughter]
cool is it really that simple bill I
wish it was evidently it isn't
um oh the nightquil baby the nightquil
what what uh what apertif do you pair
Nyquil with um I had a Caesar's salad
with NyQuil oh my God that's
amazing did you take a picture of it and
put it on
Instagram all right let's do the
advertising for this
week uh Simply Safe everybody when
everyone wants to be and what everyone
would be if they weren't [__]
murderous psycho [__] lunatics in the
world all all right it's still
October but the holidays are coming up
fast before your life goes into
overdrive with the holidays protect your
home with Simply Safe home security you
can get a brand new system today for 40%
off experts love Simply Safe it was
named the best home security system of
2023 by US News and World Report Simply
Safe is a comprehensive protection it's
is comprehensive comprehensive
protection what does comprehensive mean
all-encompassing overwhelming uh
protection for the whole home with
Advanced sensors that detect break-ins
fires floods and
More Jesus floods I could have used that
[__] 10 years ago plus HD cameras for
both inside and out it's powered by 24/7
professional monitoring for less than a
dollar a day half the cost of
traditional home security with new 24/7
live guard protection and Smart Alarm
Wireless indoor camera monitoring agents
can see and speak to Intruders helping
stop crime in real time I want to be one
of those
people you
know a powerful you know that yells at
the criminal you know what the ultimate
home security is is [__] once the
person's in your house not only do you
catch them they can't get out you know
and these [__] all these [__]
doors come down on all the windows and
all of that [__] right and then like a
[__] Mountain line comes out from the
[Laughter]
kitchen um you know what if I and if
elected everyone would have lead [__]
uh
curtains that come down like a like a
rich person's flat screen TV out of the
[__] ceiling they would come down
down over your [__] and everybody would
get one Mount
line would come out and [__] eat them
alive uh with 247 liveu protection in
the Smart Alarm Wireless indoor camera
monitoring agents can see and speak to
Intruders hey I see what you're doing
there put it down satisfaction is backed
by simply safe's money back guarantee uh
try Simply Safe for 60 days risk-free if
you don't love it if you don't love it
return your system for a full refund for
a limited time save 40% on any new
system with a fast protection plan visit
simplysafe
docomomo safe like Simply
Safe holy Jesus Mary and Joseph look who
it is it's policy
genius you've heard of policies well
this is the
genius level you know the holidays not
only allow us to spend time with family
or avoid them depending on your
situation but are a reminder of how
important our responsibility is to
protect them that includes planning to
secure their future yes they need a
[__] bag when you die life insurance
is an easy way to give your family peace
of mind or a motive to whack you
Bo it provides a safety net so if
something you were to happen to you your
family can cover expenses while getting
back on their feet uh luckily policy
genius helps you compare your options
from top companies and their team of
license experts are on hand to help talk
you through it yeah they weighed through
all of the [__] uh even if you
already have a life insurance policy
through work it may not offer enough
protection for your family's needs and
it may not follow you if you leave your
job [__] [__] uh with policy
genius yeah and I bet they keep the
money that you pay paid into right
that's another way that's another way
they get you oh they're always trying to
get you with policy genius you can find
life insurance policies that start at
just
$292 per year for 1 million of cover $1
million of coverage put a [__] green
light on yourself some options after
offer same day approval and avoid
unnecessary medical exams yeah you look
fine policy genius has licensed
award-winning agents
oh were they did they used to be stars
on sitcoms uh who can help you find the
best fit for your needs they work for
you not the insurance companies none of
them have a [__] side deal that means
they don't have an incentive to
recommend one insurer over another no
one's in their ear so you can trust
their guidance policy genius is for
parents caregivers and anyone else who
has people who depend on them they simp
they simplify the process of getting
life insurance so you can protect the
people you love and write out the people
you
don't no wonder they have why no wonder
they have thousands of five-star reviews
on Google and trust pilot your family
deserves peace of mind a life insurance
policy through policy genius can give it
to them uh head to policygenius.com
birth you're not a genius like me it's p
o l i
y do GE n i u
.cb or click the link in the description
to get your life insurance quotes and
see how much you could save that's how
dumb I am I think you're a genius if you
can sell if you can spell policy and
genius that's
policy. genius have I been saying this
wrong the whole
time.com
billb I thought it was policygenius.com
man am I [__] mind
here I don't know know you'll figure it
out or end up on a porn
site um all right here we go we're going
to get into the reads this week the
reads we're going to the weeds with the
reads and it Rhymes so you know it's
[__] true all right
Dynasty all right hey old Billy shark
attack oh Jesus I told you somebody sent
me a
[__] video of a [__] a person just
getting eaten by a goddamn shark I don't
know what in the [__] people are doing
swimming out in the [__] ocean that
far out I don't know what the [__]
you're
doing
uh Jesus [__]
Christ um anyway hey old Billy shark
attack by the way I finally watched the
Moto GP race I just watched the last one
uh fantastic [__] race I'm a Ducati
guy I thought for a second you know he
did that pass around the outside I knew
it was going to happen though once he
slammed on the braks Brad binder and the
other fellow there we're going to go by
him uh that's shaping up to be be a
great end of the year it's going to come
down on the last race huh firstly the
only pull-ups you'll be doing at 70 will
be putting on your adult
diaper that's a great goddamn joke if I
wasn't babbling that would have got a
bigger laugh hey old Billy shark attack
first firstly the only pull-ups you'll
be doing at 70 will be putting on your
adult diapers
wow you know guys this agism stuff
really has to stop but war is fine uh
for rugby fans like myself an example of
a dynasty would be the New Zealand All
Blacks oh yeah I don't know [__] about
rugby but I know you do not
[__] with New Zealand All Blacks they
they do that that that I don't know I
don't know what I don't know what the
song is called they sing this [__]
song it's like imagine somebody at
karaoke all right and right before they
went up to sing they just found out that
their wife [__] their best
friend that's the look on their face
when they come up there you
[Music]
know and they're going to blame you and
you know what and you're the one that
[__] their wife that is their Vibe all
right I watch that [__] and I'm just
like I can't believe the other team
doesn't immediately
forfeit uh anyway winning back-to-back
World Cups in 2011 and 2015 with an
unbeaten 14g Game season this is the All
Blacks in 2013 and a 90% win rate of
those four years between 20 2011
and 2015 is saying that that's a dynasty
I don't have a problem with any of those
numbers uh I know you don't like
responding to rugby fans why I love
rugby I actually started watching it I
know that uh was it South Africa just
won the [__] uh World Cup and they
beat New Zealand correct I'm paying
attention well I have a friend that's
into it
uh because the USA suck at
it um you know rugby fans the worst
thing you can do is is get America
involved in
rugby all right we have more money than
you we have better drugs okay our
drugged up guys are going to come down
there and just beat the [__] out of you
I don't give a [__] what song they sing
uh but World rugby have expanded the
next tournament increasing it by four
teams to make it near impossible for the
us to not make
it in the queue it make it in Q USA
still
failing all right first of all sir like
I don't understand why you're trashing
us about not doing well in a sport that
we don't give a [__] about do you know
every four years we don't win the world
cup and soccer and nobody cares nobody
cares okay we have our four [__]
sports that's what we care about and we
call them World Championships because we
don't give a [__] about you guys all
right and that's why you can't stop
paying attention to us we're like that
hot chick you just want us to give a
[__] oh look what I did I won a World
Cup and soccer we don't give a [__] I
don't give a [__] about your [__]
pickle ball I don't give a [__] about
what I don't give a [__] I respect it I
don't have the [__] time I don't have
the time to watch NBA basketball it
comes on the same time as the NHL you
got to pick a sport all right I don't
give a [__]
all right so stop like I don't it's like
you're lit you're fighting a one-way War
here buddy yeah yeah you dominate Us in
rugby we suck at rugby okay guess what I
could do I can get on with my life and
and I can forget you said that within
five [__] minutes it be like me
trashing you that you're not good at
American
football like how hard would you laugh
if I you got you be like that's not even
a [__] sport you guys don't even
respect the [__] sport you know say
what you want about rugby like I I like
I
people are done playing football over
here they have like [__] brain damage
and they snap and they start shooting at
cops or kill their whole family or kill
themselves like I I don't see that
happen in
rugby uh but anyways you know I you know
what hey you guys yeah you guys are
better than us anyway still enjoying
most of the content content glue and go
[__]
yourself uh whatever that means all
right well there you
go I actually really really enjoy rug I
think it's an amazing [__] Sport and
I can live happily the rest of my life
if the USA never even had a team or if
we never got in I just I just don't give
a
[__] I don't know when it starts I don't
know when it
ends all right you just had the
championship so I'm going to say it
starts maybe in April or May do you play
for six months is there some sort of
metric system do you have an extra month
in the summer that we don't know about I
don't [__]
know uh how many Stanley Cups have you
won in the in [__] New
Zealand huh take that [__]
Auckland uh Pakistani fan uh dear Billy
burlap um I often h i now I'm getting a
[__] hot here am I going through
menopause you know it's overrated
[__] flannel pajamas is it ever cold
enough that these things are it's you
know what this is good about
when you [__] forgot to bring out the
trash barrels that's when it's good to
be wearing flannel pajamas when you're
outside you know and you get attacked by
a bear you know and the flannel acts as
like a
repellent you know like you know that
fish that if they if you bite it it the
other fish bite it it makes their their
mouth all stuck together I think flannel
pajamas would do
that um people at flanel pajamas never
get killed by bears I'll tell you how if
you buy my book dear Billy burlap I
often have your podcast or Netflix
specials playing in the background while
I'm at
work well I would say you're not doing a
good job all right how about you focus a
little bit anyway I'm a big fan of yours
from Islam
Islamabad Pakistan all right that's
[__]
great what's up to you and everybody in
Islamabad who just wants to find love
you know and be okay and not to fight
Wars wouldn't that be
fantastic uh I appreciate how
knowledgeable you are about so many
things all right I feel like a right
hook coming this is too many compliment
Finance human relationship Dynamics and
human beings in general people are alike
all over there you go that's right he
said I worry about the US dollar
collapsing oh well that's why we keep
getting involved in Wars isn't it so we
can up our level of debt so the Ponzi
scheme continues at some point the
checks coming
people and we're going to have to
tighten our belts and put our pants on
one [__] leg at a time um he says our
currency or she says is called the
rupee our government prints it into
Oblivion just like
yours oh wow that's amazing so I guess
the Federal Reserve does if they weren't
doing it the government wouldn't be it's
not the global Reserve currency so our
cap capacity to ruin it for everyone
isn't as
much um
this is a wild time to be living in man
this is doesn't this feel like we're
getting into the third Act of a Tom Cruz
or Will Smith movie anyway I hope you
visit Pakistan sometime we are the
world's fifth biggest country by
population and 36th biggest by land area
you know what I would love to go over
there but I'm just worried about what my
government has done there and then I'm
going to be the sacrificial lamb okay to
be honest with you we don't exactly uh
you know we've done the Irish goodbye to
a lot of countries is all I'm saying uh
i' it'd be a dream come true to see you
talking to an audience of college kids
here I would love to do that English is
an official language here we were we
were ruled by the British oh what a
surprise uh the nerve of those [__] to
look down on Americans like we're
[__]
[__] you know you guys raised us all
right all of our Behavior we learned
from you uh anyway and we separated out
of India to create a more religiously
tolerant country parenthesis we [__]
that
up oh I know you guys in India don't get
along that's terrible because I've met
Pakistani people I've met Indian people
and you you're [__] great people you
guys are funny too so stupid the whole
[__] thing is so [__] stupid it's
like I was in Reno that's such a [__]
beautiful city if our government gave a
[__] and helped those people out you
know but there's no money in helping out
nice people I don't know what it is I I
just don't get it anyway we're one of
the most badly affected by climate
change Nations oh God we have the most
glaciers outside of the North and South
Poles Himalayas
and carac corm mountains I can imagine
you struggling to pronounce this oh yeah
well I did uh as those glaciers melt we
have a lot more flooding I know it's a
convention a convention to insult you at
the
end but I respect you far too much to do
that bless you you bring smiles to
millions of people and make the world a
better place by being in it all right
I'm such an I had such an abusive
childhood that I feel like you're
buttering me up to go over there so you
and 10 friends could beat the [__] out
of
me I'm [__] with you that's very nice
of you thank you a fan of yours from
Islam Abad I hope I said that right uh
well that that was nice see look at that
every once in a
while you could be nice and respectful
uh well you know what that's amazing
that you even know who the hell I am and
I I imagine you must have a gorgeous
country and uh I'm sorry for the climate
change you know oops we're going to turn
it around though people we're going to
figure way clean up the ocean we're
going to straighten up and fly right
something's going to happen something
positive is going to
happen um I now have my pajama top is
just completely unbuttoned I'm looking
at my pasty belly and I just I
look I don't know what I look like I I
look unemployed that's what I look like
but it's at night so you think all right
maybe he gets his [__] together and
actually goes to
work uh how to win an argument with a
woman from a mental health
counselor okay hey Billy cheese head I'm
an Ecuadorian living living in the
United States welcome uh it happens to
be that I am also a mental health
counselor well I bet you get plenty of
work over
here you know [__] you can start with
me uh I wanted to tell you the secrets
on how to win an argument with your
woman I like the way you said my woman I
like how possessive that is I don't
think that's toxic toxic at all I just
feel like I just added an asset to my
portfolio uh I never have the opport to
say it in my private practice during
coup's therapy because women usually
take most of the time and I never have
the time to explain this in logical
terms oh Jesus Christ dude I mean if I
could [__] buy you a beer right now I
mean that's one of the most beautiful
sentences I'm going to read that again I
never have the opportunity to say it in
my private practice during coup's
therapy because women usually take up
most of the time and I never have the
time to explain this in logical terms
I mean if I know how to take a hammer
and a chisel and carve that into a giant
rock I I I I would do it now the
solution is easy just [__]
acknowledge their emotion before you
present your logical
argument okay it's it's that easy it's
like a glitch in The Matrix just say I
see you are upset or whatever [__]
emotion you think they are experiencing
and then present your argument if you do
this I can get guarantee you that you
will win every aru every argument that
sounds like some late night TV [__] all
right and I'll show you how to do it for
1995 please try it out because you need
to practice this before you actually use
it all right I'm going to try that when
I get off this
podcast I had a headache and I asked my
wife where the Tylenol was and she
didn't [__] say anything so I had a
rumag through all the goddamn drawers
and I found it myself all right and then
she comes in she goes did you find the
Tylenol and I'm like
yeah she goes what's wrong I go you
didn't even help me I asked you for help
and you didn't even say anything she
goes what are you talking about I told
you that our son got up and I had to put
him to
bed and then he said he had to go potty
and I'm like you said all of that and I
didn't hear any all I heard was silence
and she said yeah and I said all right
okay okay all right you know well that's
where we're
at but that was one of the deals that I
was upset I don't know I guess I'll have
to buy your second book anyways I hope
this free counseling advice helps my
fellow men and women that have to deal
with this [__] huge fan and please
go hug yourself look at it's all [__]
positive this
week
um I ended on a good note though I
always end on a good note I I don't do
that going to bed [__] angry you know
uh
stupid makes you have [__] up dreams
about buying a motorcycle and just
riding away from everything
uh mood
enhancer I could use a [__] mood
enhancer right
now I'm going to do it in the form of
liquid death everybody death to
plastic look at this I just snuck a
plugin it's almost like I invested in
the company and I you can't [__]
trust
me oh God damn it that's that's [__]
fresh Mountain Water right from
somebody's
faucet uh mood enhancer dear bill I have
a secret to make I have a secret to make
oh I have a secret to make you more at
ease with trials and tribulations of the
world all right hang on one [__]
second I go to I got to handle something
this is disgusting but I'm going to do
it Jesus Christ couldn't hit
pause
uh all right all right this last person
just taught me how to [__] win an
argument with a woman every time time oh
God now it's going down my throat I'm
sound like I'm going through puberty and
then the other guy I got somebody from
Pakistan that to bless you what a
[__] nice thing to
say um anyway I know you're a n a Nature
Boy and think the Earth is beautiful so
you might so this might work with
you I I mean I'm not I'm not an
Outdoorsman I like being outside that's
just because my responsibilities are
inside that's why I like my back
porch I sit on the porch there's nothing
to do I go inside oh God this [__] this
stuff is
happening anyway this person is going to
help me the trials and tribulations of
the world I know you're a Nature Boy and
think the Earth is beautiful so this
might work for you before bed I now want
much 15 minutes of David Attenborough
narrated Earth documentary oh how can
you do that every [__] animal they
talk about they go it's now endangered
in the end they get you to love the
[__] thing and then they say why it's
[__] up someone's taking a [__]
dump in their bird nest or something
bird's nest uh anything where he's
talking about a simple or complex
creature or ecosystem and I
start and I start to feel small and
think the Earth will be fine without us
oh it would be fantastic without us but
we would have to clean it up
you know if we all just [__] died
that wouldn't be the solution cuz the
nuclear reactors would overheat and then
it would [__] wipe everybody out okay
I saw that one time on a [__] nature
show anyway this person says I started
this after I was told my pre-br ritual
of watching videos on my phone and
falling asleep the TV was making me on
edge every morning ah look at that okay
I I'll go with that do you have a
pre-bed ritual a glass of worn milk you
Twinkle Toes
dude you guys are [__] funny
man I got funny ass [__] listen I
don't laugh well I do I laugh a lot I I
actually do laugh a lot but you these
are legit [__] jokes thanks for the
laugh thank you for the laugh a glass of
warm milk you Twinkle Toes let's do
there's another good Joker there this
one was
amazing what is it what is the the
[__] depends
one the only pull-up she'll be doing is
70 will be putting on your adult diapers
that could be on one of those [__]
Comedy Central roasts that get a laugh
look at you guys you guys are all grown
up all these years listen to the podcast
you're [__] telling better jokes than
me
um what is my pre-bed
ritual
uh you know what I do I I don't know I
just do what I always do I shoot the
[__] with my wife joke around and trying
to make her
laugh you know and then I make fun of
whatever [__] reality TV show she's
watching I like to do that but you know
there's no learning that's what you're
saying do I do I do I like pray do I
[__] yeah no I don't do anything I
whatever you
know listen to me I can't even finish a
[__] sentence I'm so [__] up I mean
granted I'm on cold medicine right now
you wouldn't be if you took the [__] you
get the [__]
[Applause]
jab uh let's be honest okay the vaccine
didn't stop you from getting coid but it
also didn't kill you all right the truth
lies somewhere in between so both sides
were right and both sides were [__]
wrong isn't that kind of what happened
and we shouldn't have been screaming and
yelling at each other we should have
been [__] relaxed but that's not what
we do we just [__] yell at each other
and then we get it all tied into
politics next thing you know people are
slamming gallons of elks down and
[__] convenience stores those [__]
[__] who wouldn't wear masks and
then they slam the gallon on milk you
want to wear mask and you having a
[__] temper fine we all [__] do it
but to slam a gallon of milk on the
[__] ground and walk out and you're
just okay that somebody else has to mop
that up that's when I wish like Brad Pit
came in from [__] uh Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood remember when that [__]
douche slashed the tires on his caddy
and he beat the [__] out of him and then
threw him the Jack and said you're you
know who's going to fix it you are and
he laughed and then he beat the [__] out
of him that kid deserved a [__]
beating back in the day A nice [__]
mop handle to the back a couple of times
and then you hand it to him okay they
would literally beat you with the thing
that they wanted you to solve the
problem with that's how that's how it
was the way I looked at it every once in
a while everybody took a
beating
um so anyway I what I'm talking about
here I have a big week coming up I got
some shows I got Billy shows Billy shows
I want to finish the year strong so it's
kind of good that I'm sick now because
uh I will
be I'll be healthy when my [__] shows
come around sorry I don't want to start
making you yawn all right I'm going to
stop here and uh I don't know what I'm
going to do I'm going to go buy that
guy's book so I'll be like an Amish
person I'm going to shave my mustache
off and just grow my beard up you know
so I just a
[__] that [__] is there anything
worse than a [__] giant beard with no
mustache you just want to be like why
are you making me look at
that um
anyway we're going to end the podcast
right there all
right we're just going to take this
podcast as a loss the way I took that
Ravens [__] game as a loss Jesus
[__] Christ um that is the podcast
everybody
um by the way you know I did see a
[__] clip ACDC If You Want Blood
you've got it is one of the greatest
[__] live albums of all time and
recently on the internet all of a sudden
there was video
which means the whole concert was
filmed so does anybody have a copy of
that like I'm so into that album you
know I've played Glasgow and I actually
tried to see if the theater was still
there so I could go play it and just
stand there and just think like ACDC at
their peak in the Bon Scott era they you
know before they had their Peak with the
Brian Johnson era
like I would have love to just [__]
stand there you know didn't happen they
[__] tore it down [__] all
right
anyway that's the podcast go [__]
yourselves bless
you hug yourself I can't I just can't do
I can't commit to that it's just it just
gives me douche chills all right go [__]
yourselves I'll check in on your
Thursday okay get on with your day for
God's
sakes